[laughter]
You're going to love this.
[rock music]
Look at him, man.
[laughter]
Check you out, Dee.
Another new car.
This car is a gift for my wife.
Nice.
I thought I'd surprise her.
You know, she and I have
been together 40 years, man.
Wow.
She's been putting up
with you for 40 years?
Yes.
Yeah, against her will.
[laughter]
Dee Snider from Twisted
Sister and I, we go way back,
and he's always
full of surprises.
DEE SNIDER: I thought I'd
surprise her with a new Z4.
Very nice.
I got it in white
because I figure
it's like a clean canvas.
[rock music]
DANNY KOKER: The Z4 is BMW's
follow-up to the wildly popular
Z3 Roadster, known
for being manufactured
in the United States.
The Z4s are being built
in Germany once again,
and a combination of beautiful
body lines, spacious interior,
and the ability to hit
60 miles per hour in 4.8
helped the Z4 win the coveted
Red Dot Design Award in 2009.
Well, brother, like Suzette,
the car is already very classy.
What direction should
we go with this, bro?
I know she's thinking pink.
Pink?
She doesn't want
it to be all pink.
I think she's thinking of
using the white with styling--
Accents.
DEE SNIDER: Accents.
OK.
I heard you requested me.
You know the-- the
Z4 BMW that we're doing
for Dee Snider's wife
for her anniversary?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Beautiful pearl white car.
He says her favorite
color is pink.
I like this one.
That's what I would
do right there.
You're absolutely no help--
none.
That's-- that's what I think.
Never mind.
You know what?
No pink.
We told Suzette that Dee had
to pick up something from me
to use on his new record.
She has no idea she's
about to get a new Beamer.
Dee, Suzette, thank you
guys for stopping by, man.
You know the thing we talked
about last time you were here?
Oh, yeah.
Is it done?
I-- yeah.
Hey Ryan, bring that
sweet ride out there.
[engine revving]
[laughter]
[rock music]
Happy anniversary.
- Wow.
Wow.
You're so sweet.
[laughter]
I love it.
I love the way you got all
the ghost patterns in there
in the metallic silver.
DANNY KOKER: Yeah.
SUZETTE SNIDER: Amazing.
RYAN EVANS: OK.
- But the truth?
Yes, ma'am.
I want pink.
RYAN EVANS: Pink.
- Yeah.
- OK.
Pink.
DANNY KOKER: Bam.
Ooh.
DANNY KOKER: Dee wanted
us to add a bit of flair
to Suzette's brand new BMW Z4.
As much bad luck as we've
had with pink around here,
I think this car looks amazing.
The pink and silver
graphics perfectly
accentuating the sexy lines
of this beautiful Beamer.
I think it's exactly
what Suzette had in mind.
At least I hope so.
I don't want to have to
take this baby back again.
[rock music]
Well, is that the
best you could do?
- Are you kidding me?
- Yeah, man.
It's great.
- Oh my god.
[laughter]
[rock music]
I love it.
It's awesome.
Thank god.
The car is fantastic, right?
Beautiful.
SUZETTE SNIDER: Yeah,
she looks beautiful.
RYAN EVANS: The right
amount of color to it?
SUZETTE SNIDER:
Yeah, it's beautiful.
Those hips like
that, that looks great.
It looks beautiful,
elegant, and sexy.
You did good.
But one thing.
Oh.
That damn wheels don't match.
[laughter]
Are you kidding me?
I did all the emblems on the
car except for the ones in the--
come on, man.
Seriously?
DEE SNIDER: Dude.
This is actually kind of fun.
I'm enjoying this
because Ryan hates
doing things more than once.
I detest it.
And now, it's
coming back again.
Why don't you drive it
down to the shop right now?
I'll take care of those
center caps, 20 minutes tops.
All right.
RYAN EVANS: Let's do it.
- I love you.
You did a great job.
You really, really
did a great job.
RYAN EVANS: Putting
me through the ringer.
Isn't that what
all women do, though?
RYAN EVANS: I love it.
I love it.
It happens.
DANNY KOKER: Yeah.
RYAN EVANS: It happens
to the best of us.
DANNY KOKER: Yeah.
Ryan?
Yes, ma'am.
You forgot something.
[laughter]
Center cap to
the steering wheel.
I got it.
I'll take care of that, too.
You'll do that.
Drive safe.
We'll see you guys down there.
RYAN EVANS: You're
buying me a drink, right?
I'm buying you four.
[laughter]
RYAN EVANS: Wow.
[siren]
[explosion]
DANNY KOKER: Really, you
missed the center caps?
Come on, man.
RYAN EVANS: I'm so sorry, dude.